ich nehme mal mit ins jahr 2014 ich bin
gerade 16 und mein tag sind ungefähr so
aus ich komme um 1 von der schule macht
den fernseher an selbst mich ein laptop
mit spielen videospiele wir sie ins bett
muss schon seit jahren aber irgendwas in
mir wollte mehr und so habe ich kraft
sport entdeckt eine phase von anderthalb
jahren beginnt in der sich mein
tagesablauf drastisch gewandelt
ohne ausnahmen punkt 22 uhr ins bett um
45 pünktlich zum frühstück wieder
aufzustehen viermal die woche für ein
zwei stunden sport und meine ernährung
wird exakt getrackt kein gramm zucker
weißmehl oder alkohol in dieser zeit hat
mir der sport gezeigt dass sich harte
arbeit auszahlt und dann kam youtube
[Musik]
und meine zeit und damit mein hart
erarbeiteter körper die haben sich in
den letzten vier jahren verabschiedet
aber ich weiß dass es mir besser gehen
würde ich weiß dass ich mich wohler
fühlen würde ich weiß auch dass es
gesünder wäre ich weiß auch dass
bewegung für den menschen essenziell ist
und ich will wissen könnte ich das immer
noch so sah ich dann vor drei monaten
aus als ich den entschluss gefasst habe
herauszufinden wie viel muskelmasse ich
drauf packen kann wenn ich 90 tage alles
gebe in diesem bild habe ich wenn wir
ehrlich sind seit vier jahren kein sport
mehr gemacht aber wie sehe ich jetzt
heute nach meiner 90 tage body
transformation hierunter aus und mir
habe ich mich dabei an gestellt ich zeig
euch dieses video wird unterstützt von
tim k die haben mir den link zu ihrem
shop geschickt und gesagt bedienen dich
und das habe ich dann auch gemacht
den link dazu findet ihr in der video
beschreibung da mein wissen was
muskelaufbau geht nach meiner langen
auszeit etwas eingerostet war musste ich
mich erst mal wieder einlesen es gibt
unzählige verschiedene meinungen aber
über eines streites niemand muskeln
entstehen in der kirche
deshalb gibt es klare regeln an die ich
mich halten möchte wie zum beispiel 3200
kilokalorien zu essen viele von euch
wenn jetzt zu recht sagen dass das
vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel ist aber
glaubt mir ich brauche da hast du wenig
zu nehmen möchte mein körper ist eine
echte stoffwechsel maschine diese 3200
kilokalorien bestehen zu 50 prozent also
340 gramm kohlenhydrate 30 prozent also
100 gramm fett und 20 prozent
beziehungsweise 115 gramm eiweiß
abgesehen nach und das natürlich wieder
einige jetzt sagen wer nicht mindestens
zehnmal so viel eiweiß ist dieser
verteilung ziemlicher klassiker im
kraftsport und sie dann auf dem teller
ungefähr so aus acht uhr haferflocken
nüsse milcheiweiß pulver eine banane 10
uhr 30 2 vollkornbrote mit humus und ein
apfel 13 uhr hühnchen mit reis viel
hühnchen mit reis 15 uhr eine packung
reiswaffeln mit einer dose kichererbsen
18 uhr linsen und bohnen 21 uhr eine
packung magerquark mit olivenöl und eine
handvoll nüsse
ich will ja auch nicht so viel essen
muss sich aber am muskel entstehen
natürlich leider nicht nur in der kirche
sondern auch beim training also haben
sebastian der diesmal ein
trainingspartner war und
trainingsplan erstellt mein
trainingsplan ist gesplittert in zwei
tage also ganz klassisch und pulm ein
pulk besteht überwiegend aus sachen in
den meinen sachen zu sich reinzieht und
sie dann ungefähr so hickel universität
diese priester soll immerhin war das bei
mir eher so aus
[Musik]
das gegenstück dazu ist dann der tag an
dem man eben sachen von sich weg drückt
[Musik]
und das ganze also push pull tag immer
abwechselnd vier mal die woche danach
bin ich auch eigentlich nicht immer
ziemlich im arsch damit wir genau wissen
wie ich mich verändere messe ich davor
mein gewicht 64,7 kilogramm und mit
einem maßband auf den umfang an allen
möglichen stellen meines körpers also
bizeps unterarm brust bauch oberschenkel
und an meinen unfassbar muskulösen
warten das ziel ist natürlich diese
zahlen alle zu vergrößern um ziele geht
es übrigens auch bei den sharks xx
challenges jim clark hat passend zur
jahresmitte nation verschiedenen
challenges ins leben gerufen bei denen
man sich selbst herausfordern kann aktiv
zu werden in verschiedenen eingerosteten
oder komplett neuen bereichen seines
lebens ähnlich wie ich das in meinen
videos immer macht das kann natürlich
auch sport und ernährung seien aber auch
soziales oder mentales wie zum beispiel
meditation die anmeldefrist der von 66
tage challenge die ich mit diesem
minimalen photoshop ein bild bereits im
dezember angekündigt habe dies zwar
bereits abgelaufen aber tim clark wird
im rahmen dieser aktion bisher jetzt
wesentlich neue challenges staaten bei
denen ihr mitmachen und preise gewinnen
könnt wenn ihr euch auf vorgenommen habt
ihr das neue jahr so richtig
durchzustarten dann ist das vielleicht
genau die richtige motivation für mich
und wenn ihr euch das noch nicht
vorgenommen habt dann macht es jetzt
mitmachen könnt ihr über den link in der
video beschreibung aller anfang ist
schwer aber ich fand den spoiler alarm
tatsächlich am leichtesten die fitness
studios waren zu dem zeitpunkt nur für
eine sehr begrenzte anzahl an menschen
gehört aber dadurch konnte man
wenigstens ohne konkurrenz eine ganzen
geräte an die krasseste veränderung für
mich war übrigens nicht mal die tatsache
dass ich mich zum ersten mal seit
jahrhunderten wieder bewegt hat sondern
die routine die das training in meinen
alltag gebracht hat das was für mich als
youtube gehalt von komplett neu war die
heftige fan truppe natürlich dieser
muskelkater nach dem ersten training
findet ja cool zu spüren dass man seine
muskeln scheinbar richtig beansprucht
erhalten der war echt unnötig ich bin
wahrscheinlich nicht der einzige mit der
meinung wenn ich sage dass das
eigentlich schwierige beim muskelaufbau
nicht das training ist versteh mich
nicht falsch das natürlich ins ausland
gibt aber auch kraft und energie zurück
das eigentlich müde daran ist die
ernährung die ich hier gerade mit seiner
app trecker dadurch aber hat natürlich
auch durch die schiere menge
erzeugt die ich nämlich rein pfeifen
muss wenn ich zu nehmen will hat sich
die zeit die mir jeden tag fürs essen
drauf geht von einer stunde auf zwei
stunden fand obwohl woche also ungefähr
sieben extrastunden was ungefähr genauso
viel es mich auch fürs training rund 14
stunden pro woche einfach mal so locker
zu machen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt so
einfach aber alles gute im leben hat
seinen preis und den will ich auch
zahlen erstes training drittes viertes
achtes training zehntes training jede
wiederholung im gym wird in die tabelle
eingetragen und jede mahlzeit getrackt
und dann kam lockdown 2.0 auf einen
schlag war die routine die ich mir
aufgebaut auf zusammen mit sebastian
ungefähr jeden zweiten tag um 11 uhr
morgens ins gym zu gehen komplett für
müll und ich muss zugeben da wieder
reinzukommen of home training
umzusteigen hat mich viel länger
gedauert als es hätte sollen und das
wird sich auch zeigen wir im training
habe ich mir dann auch dieses setup im
international ist dass wir vorher schon
mal gesehen habe also ich damit dann
wieder rangekommen bin fand ich es
zuhause zu trainieren eigentlich echt
besser man kann jederzeit umgestellt
loslegen auch drei uhr nachts und so
eine hantelbank handeln und eine matte
mit den ich übrigens alle übungen aus
dem fitnessstudio und alle maschinen
ersetzen konnte
wir sind nach ein paar monaten auch viel
günstiger als ein fitnessstudio
mitgliedschaft wegen koma wäre das auch
schon von anfang an die bessere
entscheidung gewesen wenn ich ehrlich
bin und dann werden uns auch nicht eins
zu eins genau so gegangen mit dem jacken
der während des ersten lockdown seine
body transformation gemacht hat und der
hat da innerhalb von vier monaten
richtig ordentlich zugelegt und jetzt
zeige ich euch mal wie viel ich in drei
monaten zugelegt habe und auch mal ein
vorher nachher bild bei mir lief das
ganze nicht komplett nach plan und damit
kommen wir wieder zum thema zeit und
youtube das hat am ende des jahres
nochmal richtig reingekriegt und hätte
eigentlich jede freie sekunde in meiner
zeit beansprucht hat jeden tag um 11 uhr
morgens wird dann irgendwann mal 21 uhr
dann wurde noch einmal trainings
verschoben oder komplett ausgelassen das
wäre eigentlich auch noch okay gewesen
und der sport zu machen auch immer noch
spaß mein richtiges problem war dass
hier
die 3200 kilokalorien in form von
gesundem essen reinzugehen und wisst ja
das hat mich echt belastet also ich
wusste halt die ganze zeit dass ich dann
nach diesen drei monaten das ergebnis
mit einer community die halt auch hohe
helfer hat trainer mich hat ja mit denen
allen teilen muss unter druck da halt
abzuliefern und mit andern auch mit zu
halten da war halt schon recht riesig
und die schuldgefühle wenn ich mal eine
mahlzeit aus zwei gründen auslassen
musste halt gigantisch aber ja der druck
ist eigentlich quatsch also ein altes
sprichwort besagt vergleiche dich nicht
mit anderen sondern mit seinem früheren
selbst und das machen weiter und zwar
mit dem vor drei monaten das noch 64,7
kilogramm wog und so aussah heute
wirklich 68,2 kilo und sehe so aus ich
habe also 3,5 kilo zugenommen und das
ist halt zugegeben schon weniger ist das
was ich mir vorgenommen habe im ersten
monat habe ich sogar zwei kilo drauf
gepackt das entspricht 500 gramm pro
woche und das ist genau das was ich mir
vorgenommen habe in den letzten beiden
monaten habe ich dann allerdings
zusammen nur 15 kilogramm zugenommen und
das lag vor allem wie gesagt am person
aber mega schlechthin heißt reinhard
keller natürlich auch nicht und man
sieht auch den unterschied gut das licht
hilft jetzt beiden bildern ein bisschen
nachts muss man zugeben aber alles in
allem eigentlichen in ordnung aber ich
weiß halt da geht eigentlich noch mehr
und ich will auch unbedingt wissen wie
sich das auf meine form auswirkt wenn
ich wirklich komplett rigoros streng
nach plan
trainiere und es in einigen monaten
planig deswegen also ein richtig
heftiges update video und hat auch schon
ein paar ideen die ich besser machen
kann dann wird es mir trotzdem gelingt
auch mit 80plus stunden woche joggt
gerne die sharks 66 challenge über den
link in der wie die beschreibung ab und
macht das ja damit so was richtig
besondere den link zum chat shop findet
ihr auch da gibt es fitness bekleidung
und accessoires und zum beispiel und ja
das klingt jetzt ein bisschen dumm aber
die bequemsten socken die ich jemals
getragen habe nächste woche kommt wieder
zum thema kickstarter wenn er das nicht
verpassen möchte abonniert uns gern an
dann sehen wir uns da wieder macht's gut
[Musik]